You might think you have a pretty good idea of what obsessive compulsive disorder entails. Maybe you've heard someone say, I'm so OCD, when they're just talking about how they like to keep a neat house or how they're always punctual. But OCD is not synonymous with liking neatness and order, and it encompasses more than just the hand washing or counting or similar compulsions that many people are familiar with. In fact, it's a multifaceted mental health disorder that seriously affects people's lives. but it's also treatable with evidence-based therapies. Today we're going to talk to two experts, a psychologist who studies OCD, and an advocate with lived experience, to do some myth-busting about this misunderstood disorder. So what is obsessive-compulsive disorder and how does it differ from the stereotypes?
你可能认为自己对强迫症（OCD）所包含的内容有相当不错的了解。也许你听过有人说“我有强迫症”，当他们只是在谈论自己喜欢保持家里整洁，或者总是很准时的时候。但强迫症并不等同于喜欢整洁和秩序，它涵盖的内容远不止许多人熟悉的洗手、计数或类似的强迫行为。事实上，它是一种多方面的心理健康障碍，严重影响人们的生活，但它也是可以通过循证疗法进行治疗的。今天，我们将与两位专家交谈——一位研究强迫症的心理学家和一位有亲身经历的倡导者，来打破关于这种被误解的疾病的一些迷思。那么，什么是强迫症，它与刻板印象有何不同？
How common is OCD in both adults and children? What causes it? What effective treatments are available? And if you or someone you love is struggling with OCD, where can you go for help and what should you look for in a treatment provider? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
强迫症在成人和儿童中有多普遍？是什么原因引起的？有哪些有效的治疗方法？如果你或你所爱的人正在与强迫症作斗争，你可以去哪里寻求帮助，在选择治疗提供者时应该寻找什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
We have two guests today. First is Dr. Dean McKay, a professor in the Department of Psychology at Fordham University, where he heads the compulsive, obsessive, and anxiety program laboratory. Dr. McKay's research focuses on the nature and treatment of obsessive compulsive disorder, as well as anxiety disorders, and the role of disgust in psychopathology. He has edited or co-edited 21 books and published more than 300 journal articles and book chapters. He is also a board certified clinical psychologist and director and founder of the Institute for Cognitive Behavior Therapy and Research, a private treatment and research center in New York. He is a past president of both a society for the science of clinical psychology and the association for behavioral and cognitive therapies.
今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是福特汉姆大学心理学系教授迪恩·麦凯博士，他负责强迫、焦虑项目实验室。麦凯博士的研究重点是强迫症的本质和治疗，以及焦虑症和厌恶感在精神病理学中的作用。他编辑或合编了21本书，发表了300多篇期刊文章和书籍章节。他也是一位获得委员会认证的临床心理学家，以及纽约一家私人治疗和研究中心——认知行为治疗与研究中心的创始人和主任。他曾担任临床心理科学学会和行为与认知疗法协会的主席。
Next is Uma Chatterjee, a neuroscience PhD student at the University of Wisconsin-Madison and an advocate with the International OCD Foundation. Her research interests include the neurobiology of OCD and neuropsychiatric disorders and novel therapeutics for psychiatric disorders, including psychedelic. compounds. She is also a peer mental health specialist. Her mental health practice and research are both informed by her experience with lifelong OCD, compounded by PTSD, young adult cancer, and other chronic illnesses. Thank you both for joining me today. It's a pleasure. Thank you for having us. Dr. McKay, I want to start with you. What are some of the most common myths or misconceptions
接下来是乌玛·查特吉，她是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的神经科学博士生，也是国际强迫症基金会的倡导者。她的研究兴趣包括强迫症和神经精神疾病的神经生物学，以及精神疾病的新型疗法，包括迷幻化合物。她也是一位同伴心理健康专家。她的心理健康实践和研究都受到她终身强迫症经历的影响，并伴有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、青年癌症和其他慢性疾病。感谢你们今天加入我的节目。不客气。谢谢邀请我们。麦凯博士，我想从你开始。你遇到的关于强迫症最常见的迷思或误解有哪些？
about OCD that you encounter and how do they differ from the actual disorder? One of the most common ones. You touched on it in the introduction that OCD is mainly expressed through meticulousness, orderliness, punctuality. Maybe every now and then someone will remark that they have some kind of proneness to checking something, that these seem to be the net and some total of what is OCDs. And that is a pretty dramatic and common misconception. One that among OCD experts, we kind of find an unfortunate one because it really trivializes the severity of this condition.
它们与实际的疾病有何不同？最常见的一个，你在介绍中提到了，即强迫症主要表现为一丝不苟、井井有条、守时。也许偶尔有人会说他们有某种检查东西的倾向，这些似乎就是强迫症的全部。这是一个非常戏剧化且常见的误解。在强迫症专家看来，这是一种不幸的误解，因为它真的淡化了这种疾病的严重性。
People who have OCD often suffer dramatically and it pervades their daily lives. And the kinds of things that are more commonly expressed as typical symptoms are things like severe washing related behavior. and an intense concern that they might get contaminated, checking behaviors that might be really quite interfering with their social life as well as just getting out and being able to work and engage in regular everyday functions, intrusive thoughts that are just absolutely horrific and terrifying and difficult to control, as well as some of the kinds of things that are stereotypically associated with the condition, but expressed at a debilitating level. So, you know, when people say that they're orderly and that's therefore OCD, they really are minimizing the way it's expressed when people have it with true clinical severity.
患有强迫症的人往往遭受巨大的痛苦，它渗透到他们的日常生活中。更常被描述为典型症状的行为包括：严重的洗涤相关行为，以及对可能被污染的强烈担忧；检查行为，这可能会严重干扰他们的社交生活，以及外出工作和进行日常活动的能力；还有那些绝对可怕、令人恐惧且难以控制的侵入性思维；以及一些与该疾病刻板印象相关，但表现程度达到致残水平的行为。所以，当人们说他们很有条理，因此就是强迫症时，他们确实是在淡化那些真正具有临床严重程度的患者的表现方式。
Now, to be fair, 99% of the population have from time to time symptoms that look a lot like OCD. The difference is the dimensionality of it. So we all occasionally, and for very good reasons, check things, try to keep things in order, wash. And these things are normative. And so when someone says, I have a little bit of OCD, the answer really is, of course you do, because that's a consequence of being alive. Well, Ms. Chatterjee, you volunteer as an advocate for the International OCD Foundation to raise awareness and educate the public about OCD. Do you encounter these myths in the work that you do every day? And how do you respond?
公平地说，99%的人偶尔会有看起来很像强迫症的症状。区别在于其维度。我们所有人偶尔都会出于正当理由检查东西、试图保持秩序、洗手。这些都是正常的。所以当有人说“我有一点强迫症”时，答案其实是“当然你有”，因为那是作为活人的一种结果。那么，查特吉女士，你作为国际强迫症基金会的志愿者，致力于提高公众对强迫症的认识和教育。你在日常工作中会遇到这些迷思吗？你是如何回应的？
All day, every day. And it's in my advocacy. It's in sharing my lived experience. It's now as a researcher and sharing my research in research settings amongst people who you would think, do you understand OCD, clinicians and psychiatrists and researchers. It's everywhere. And I think it is really difficult to both be holding the professional aspect of having to explain what the disorder actually is, but also holding this sadness within me of, oh, so you're saying that the thing that crippled me and debilitated me for decades is just a quirk or an adjective or something that's flippant and doesn't even. need the amount of research that it does. So yeah, I deal with it all of the time. It's most often portrayed as a quirk or an adjective. People say, I'm so OCD all the time, which doesn't even
每天都在遇到。在我的倡导工作中，在分享我的亲身经历时，甚至现在作为一名研究人员，在那些你认为应该了解强迫症的临床医生、精神科医生和研究人员的圈子里，它无处不在。我认为，既要承担解释这种疾病实际情况的专业责任，又要承受内心的悲伤，这真的很困难——“哦，所以你是说那个折磨我、让我瘫痪了几十年的东西，只是一个怪癖、一个形容词，或者是一个轻浮的、甚至不需要那么多研究的东西？”所以是的，我一直都在处理这个问题。它最常被描绘成一种怪癖或形容词。人们总是说“我太强迫症了”，这在语法上甚至
syntactically make sense. Nobody says, I'm so obsessive, compulsive disorder. That doesn't even make logical sense. And to Dr. McKay's point, yes, everybody, every single human being experiences intrus of thoughts or fears. They also sometimes might have habitual behavior, but the key aspect that most people don't experience is the disorder part, the fact that it could take at least one hour per day of your entire life and for people with severe experiences like myself, sometimes 12 to 16 hours of our day, if not more, if we're not, you know, sleeping. So it's also often seen as just a more extreme form of anxiety, which is not true based on the research. There's so many other aspects of OCD as well. Some people don't even experience anxiety as part of their OCD. So there's so many
都不通。没有人会说“我太强迫症障碍了”。这在逻辑上甚至说不通。正如麦凯博士所指出的，是的，每个人，每一个人类都会经历侵入性思维或恐惧。他们有时也可能有习惯性行为，但大多数人没有经历的关键方面是“障碍”部分，即它可能每天占用你生命中至少一个小时，对于像我这样有严重经历的人来说，有时如果不是在睡觉，甚至会占用我们每天12到16个小时。所以它也常被视为焦虑的一种更极端形式，根据研究，这是不正确的。强迫症还有许多其他方面。有些人甚至不会将焦虑作为强迫症的一部分来体验。所以有太多的
myths and misconceptions. But I think the biggest one is that people with OCD like what they're doing. So when people say, I'm so OCD about cleaning or I'm so OCD about ordering things or about things being perfect, number one, that's again, syntactically incorrect. But number two, also, it's implying that I like something a certain way and I need it that way because I really, really like it. And people with OCD hate what they're doing. They do not want to be doing what they're doing. they do not want to be thinking about what they're doing, it is not a choice at all. So just really a difference between what's egosentonic versus what's egotistonic. So Dr. McKay, we've talked a little bit about some of the manifestations, but there are different subtypes of OCD, right?
迷思和误解。但我认为最大的一点是，人们认为强迫症患者喜欢他们正在做的事情。所以当人们说“我在清洁方面太强迫症了”或者“我在整理东西或追求完美方面太强迫症了”，第一，这在语法上又是错误的。但第二，这也暗示了我喜欢某种方式，我需要它那样，因为我真的非常喜欢它。而强迫症患者讨厌他们正在做的事情。他们根本不想做他们正在做的事情，他们不想去想他们正在做的事情，这根本不是一种选择。所以这确实是“顺应强迫”（ego-syntonic）与“反强迫”（ego-dystonic）之间的区别。那么麦凯博士，我们已经谈到了一些表现形式，但强迫症有不同的亚型，对吧？
Yeah. Can you explain what some of those are? Sure. And so by way of introduction, the idea of subtypes is that as a condition, obsessive-compulsive disorder is highly varied. The term that we might use is what we call heterogeneous. And so I named a couple of subtypes that are based on symptoms. So symptoms could be in different categories such as washing symptoms, which many people in the public understand to be associated with OCDs, so washing and concerns with contamination.
是的。你能解释一下其中一些吗？当然。作为介绍，亚型的概念是，作为一种疾病，强迫症是高度多样的。我们可能使用的术语是“异质性”。所以我列举了几个基于症状的亚型。症状可以分为不同的类别，例如洗涤症状，许多公众认为这与强迫症有关，即洗涤和对污染的担忧。
Then another, shall we say, symptom subtype involves checking stuff, making sure that things are not going to pose a danger down in the future, like making sure the door is locked, making sure the stove is off, those also kind of stereotypically associated with the condition, but again, when expressed in this rather extreme way, then there's this category of symptoms that are primarily due to intrusive thoughts, like horrific thoughts of maybe unwanted urge is to harm someone, unwanted thoughts about blasphemy, things that are in this, forbidden realm where the person absolutely doesn't wish these things to happen, but they nevertheless occur to them.
另一个，我们可以说是症状亚型，涉及检查东西，确保事情在未来不会造成危险，比如确保门锁好了，确保炉子关了，这些也算是与该疾病刻板印象相关的，但同样，当以这种相当极端的方式表现出来时，就属于这一类。然后还有一类症状主要是由于侵入性思维引起的，比如可能伤害某人的可怕的、不想要的冲动，关于亵渎的不想要的想法，这些处于禁忌领域的事情，当事人绝对不希望这些事情发生，但它们却依然出现在他们的脑海中。
So those are some symptom subtypes. There are other expressions of the condition marked by things like a sense that things are not complete or a sense that I need to get something just right, even though there's a kind of arbitrary designation as to what is correct or not correct like the way things are placed on the table or the way a door closes. and if it doesn't sound quite right, that you might have to redo it. So that would be another manifestation. In the introduction for my co-presenter for Uma, an emerging recognized subtype is when people have OCD and co-occurring trauma.
这些是一些症状亚型。还有其他表现形式，其特征是诸如“事情不完整”的感觉，或者“我需要把事情做得恰到好处”的感觉，尽管对于什么是正确或不正确有一种武断的指定，比如东西放在桌子上的方式或关门的方式。如果听起来不太对劲，你可能不得不重做。所以这将是另一种表现。在为我的共同演讲者乌玛做的介绍中，一个新兴的公认亚型是当人们同时患有强迫症和创伤时。
We understand that in order to address that particular kind of co-occurring symptom presentation, it may require a different approach to treatment. So there's a variety of ways that this condition manifests that make it really complicated to treat when presented. And I guess foreshadowing a little bit where I know we're going to go for our discussion, it's what really calls for the need for specialized treatment. So, let me ask you, can you tell us some of your story and have you struggled with some of the compulsions that we've been talking about so far? Yes, absolutely. So I, according to my clinicians, they're pretty sure I was born with OCD, and that's because of the severity of my symptoms. And for how long I can go back and remember that I have been buried in obsessions and have just done compulsions to try to have any semblance of control without knowing I had OCD. So I also grew up in a first generation immigrant household with virtually no understanding of psychiatric conditions, mental health conditions, or the concept of mental health.
我们理解，为了解决那种特定的共病症状表现，可能需要一种不同的治疗方法。因此，这种疾病有多种表现方式，使得它在出现时治疗起来非常复杂。我想，稍微预示一下我们讨论的方向，这正是为什么需要专门治疗的原因。那么，让我问你，你能告诉我们一些你的故事吗？你是否一直在与我们目前讨论的那些强迫行为作斗争？是的，绝对是。根据我的临床医生的说法，他们很确定我天生就有强迫症，这是因为我症状的严重程度。我可以追溯到很久以前，记得我一直沉浸在强迫观念中，并做过强迫行为，试图在不知道自己患有强迫症的情况下获得任何一点控制感。所以我也在一个第一代移民家庭中长大，几乎完全不了解精神疾病、心理健康状况或心理健康的概念。
So it took me very, very long to get a diagnosis and proper treatment. But outside of a lack of access to proper care, it was also hugely perpetuated, the time and the delay to my proper treatment by the complete lack of understanding of what OCD was. So my mom used to bug me about cleaning my room growing up. And I would just be upset with her and say, gosh, stop being so OCD about cleaning. Like I was one of those people as well. I had no idea whatsoever. But from a young age, I was severely, severely anxious and disgust prone. And I had these obsessions as a young
所以，我花了很长时间才得到诊断和适当的治疗。但除了缺乏获得适当护理的机会外，对强迫症是什么的完全缺乏了解，也极大地延长了我获得适当治疗的时间和延迟。所以，我妈妈过去常因为我打扫房间而唠叨我。我会对她生气，说：“天哪，别在打扫卫生上那么强迫症了。”就像我当时也是那些人中的一员。我完全不知道。但从很小的时候起，我就非常、非常焦虑，而且容易感到厌恶。作为一个小孩，我有这些强迫观念：
kid of what if my parents don't come home? What if they die? And I was taught these prayers growing up to be able to try to control reality, or at least that's what my brain interpreted them as. And so these 12 prayers, I would have to do them 39 times every single time I had this thought in order to neutralize it. And it sounds absolutely absurd, right? And that's just the beginning of my whole. OCD story, but that is just largely how it showed up as a kid. But I think it became even more pervasive as I, you know, grew up in something very horrible about OCD is that there's really no bounds as to what it can latch itself onto. Like whatever, you know, a fear, like whatever fears one interacts, especially going through traumatic experiences, like OCD will latch on to absolutely
“如果我的父母不回家怎么办？如果他们死了怎么办？”我在成长过程中被教导这些祈祷文，试图控制现实，或者至少我的大脑是这样解读它们的。所以这12个祈祷文，每次我有这个想法时，我都必须做39次，以便中和它。这听起来绝对荒谬，对吧？这只是我整个强迫症故事的开始，但这在很大程度上就是它作为一个孩子出现的方式。但我认为，随着我长大，它变得更加普遍。关于强迫症，非常可怕的一点是，它真的没有界限，不知道它会附着在什么上面。就像无论什么恐惧，无论一个人在经历创伤经历时与什么恐惧互动，强迫症都会附着在绝对
everything. And so for me, it started taking up every single aspect of my life. It was to the point where I was so afraid when I was around 18 to 20 years old of being homeless that I couldn't even turn the lights on. And I had to sit in the darkness because I was so afraid that what if I spent too much money on an electricity bill and I lose all this money and I become homeless and I, you know, can't function anymore. I couldn't go to the grocery store without spending eight hours there. And this is not a choice. Once again, this was absolutely debilitating. I would go to the grocery store and I had to compulsively compare every single product. Like if I had to get toilet paper. I had to compare every single product and figure out what is the best decision,
一切事物上。所以对我来说，它开始占据我生活的每一个方面。到了我18到20岁左右的时候，我非常害怕无家可归，以至于我甚至不敢开灯。我不得不坐在黑暗中，因为我太害怕了，如果我花太多钱在电费上，我就会失去所有的钱，变得无家可归，我无法再正常生活。我甚至不能去杂货店，除非在那里花上八个小时。这不是一种选择。再一次，这绝对是致残的。我会去杂货店，不得不强迫性地比较每一个产品。比如如果我必须买卫生纸，我必须比较每一个产品，弄清楚什么是最好的决定，
what costs the least amount of money per unit, what's going to get the job done? And then once I would actually finally make that decision, eight hours later, not exaggerating, I would then leave, then I'd return back to the store to return it. I would go make a different decision. I would just be consumed. I couldn't function. I couldn't live my life. And it was to the point where, you know, it got worse and worse and worse through my adolescence. What's important to note is that I was hospitalized for attempts on my life. And largely that was because, of OCD, but I was diagnosed with generalized anxiety disorder, a major depressive disorder. And yes, I did and do have those, but I also had severe OCD and nobody knew it because,
什么每单位成本最低，什么能完成任务？然后，一旦我终于在八个小时后做出了那个决定——我没有夸张——我就会离开，然后我会回到商店去退货。我会去做出一个不同的决定。我只是被消耗了。我无法正常生活。我无法过我的生活。到了那种地步，你知道，它在我的青春期变得越来越严重。需要注意的是，我曾因自杀未遂而住院。在很大程度上，这是因为强迫症，但我被诊断为广泛性焦虑症、重度抑郁症。是的，我确实有，而且现在也有这些，但我也有严重的强迫症，没有人知道，因为
yeah, what I just talked about were my physical compulsions. But number one, I didn't know that I was supposed to talk about it. I didn't know it was abnormal. Nobody had made me feel like this is something people don't do. It's really easy to hide with OCD. But also, what we're going to get to later, mental compulsions, those were the vast majority of what I experienced. I was constantly just ruminating, mentally reviewing my memories.
是的，我刚才谈到的是我的身体强迫行为。但第一，我不知道我应该谈论它。我不知道这是不正常的。没有人让我觉得这是人们不会做的事情。强迫症真的很容易隐藏。但同样，正如我们稍后会谈到的，心理强迫行为，那是我经历的绝大部分。我一直在反刍，在脑海中回顾我的记忆。
I had pathological doubt about everything that happened to me. And so with that, I went first misdiagnosed until I was about 13. Then I was misdiagnosed until I was 22 years old. And at that point, when I was 22, I had dropped out of college with the 1.83 GPA because I could not function whatsoever. I would go to class and I would be so consumed by what if I don't understand everything, what if I don't write everything down? So I spend my entire college class trying to write every single, literally every single word that the professor said down.
我对发生在我身上的一切都有病态的怀疑。因此，我第一次被误诊是在13岁左右。然后我一直被误诊到22岁。在那时，当我22岁时，我以1.83的平均绩点从大学退学，因为我根本无法正常学习。我会去上课，但我会被“如果我不理解一切怎么办？如果我没有把一切都写下来怎么办？”的想法所困扰。所以我花整节大学课试图写下教授说的每一个字，字面上的每一个字。
I could not skip over a word. And of course, as I'm writing things down, I'm missing what they're saying. So then I started compulsively recording all of my classes, then going home and reviewing them over and over and over again until I just burnt out. So I was at a complete loss. I had internalized it as I'm just too stupid to do this. I don't belong here. I need to leave college. And it got to the point at 22 where I was sitting in the dark. I couldn't go to. the grocery store. I started living with my partner, now husband, and let me tell you, living with someone really shows you how different your behaviors are than other people. And so when I started like freaking out at the fact that he would turn the lights on or that he would use like a whole toilet, a whole piece of toilet paper, God forbid, or a whole piece of paper towel, it sounds absurd,
我不能跳过一个字。当然，当我写下这些东西时，我错过了他们正在说的话。所以我开始强迫性地录下我所有的课，然后回家一遍又一遍地复习它们，直到我精疲力竭。所以我完全不知所措。我把它内化为“我太笨了，做不到这一点。我不属于这里。我需要离开大学。”到了22岁，我坐在黑暗中，我不能去杂货店。我开始和我的伴侣，也就是现在的丈夫住在一起，让我告诉你，和别人住在一起真的会让你看到你的行为与其他人有多么不同。所以当我开始因为他开灯，或者他会用整张卫生纸，天哪，或者整张纸巾而抓狂时，这听起来很荒谬，
right? But that's the thing about OCD. Some of the worst parts of OCD is that as suffers, we have a sense of the fact that this is illogical and we cannot override. it because of the neural circuitry in our brains, at least without treatment, we can't override it. So all of it to say, at 22, I was finally diagnosed, but that was because I started realizing that I was doing things repetitively. I went to a psychologist. They said, yes, you have OCD. Then they proceeded to treat me completely incorrectly for OCD with traditional cognitive
对吧？但这就是强迫症的特点。强迫症最糟糕的部分之一是，作为患者，我们意识到这是不合逻辑的，但我们无法克服它，因为我们大脑中的神经回路，至少在没有治疗的情况下，我们无法克服它。所以总而言之，在22岁时，我终于被诊断出来了，但那是因为我开始意识到我在重复做事情。我去看了一位心理学家。他们说：“是的，你有强迫症。”然后他们继续用传统的认知疗法完全错误地治疗我的强迫症。
behavioral therapy. Dr. McKay actually has an amazing article of many of the psychotherapies that are contraindicated and make things worse for OCD because they're not, they just reinforce compulsions. but that's what I experienced for three more years. So a diagnosis wasn't even enough because who was treating me did not know how to treat it. I was also treated with psychodynamic therapy. So we were trying to find the root cause of all of my fears so that if we just got over the trauma, then I would be fine and that obviously didn't work.
行为疗法。麦凯博士实际上有一篇非常棒的文章，列举了许多禁忌的心理疗法，这些疗法反而会加重强迫症，因为它们不仅无效，还会强化强迫行为。但这正是我在那三年里所经历的。所以，仅仅确诊是不够的，因为治疗我的人根本不知道如何治疗它。我还接受过心理动力学治疗。我们试图找出我所有恐惧的根源，认为只要克服了创伤，我就会好起来，但这显然没有奏效。
And finally, once again, I was fully debilitated, but also telling myself that I'm supposed to be getting better. And what really got me to finally get evidence-based treatment was the fact that I kind of had just started sitting on my hand. metaphorically and literally to not do compulsions. And at that point, from 22 to 25, I thought that compulsions were just physical. So I was like, if I just don't do these compulsions, I'm fine. And so I would sit on my hands and I would not do them. My husband was around, so he held me accountable to it. But then after the pandemic, he went back to work. I was alone at home
最后，我再次陷入了完全丧失功能的状态，但同时又告诉自己我应该会好起来。真正促使我最终接受循证治疗的原因是，我开始在隐喻和字面上都“坐在自己的手上”，以避免进行强迫行为。在那时，从22岁到25岁，我以为强迫行为只是身体上的。所以我心想，只要我不做这些强迫行为，我就没事了。于是我坐在手上，不去执行它们。我丈夫在身边，他监督我执行。但疫情过后，他回去工作了，我独自在家，
doing school. And I had returned back to school at that point. And I realized, I started doing my physical compulsions again. I realized I had relapsed. So I started Googling. And with my 25-year-old brain, I was then able to finally find the International OCD Foundation. I realized exposure and response prevention was a thing, and that was the actual treatment for OCD. I could not believe that in 25 years I had never heard of this and that I was being incorrectly treated this whole time. I finally started engaging with ERP. I gained so much of my life back. I went from someone with a 1.83 GPA to coming back to school, retaking all of my classes with straight A's. I got my bachelor's in psychology. I got my master's in neuroscience at the 4.0. I'm now a PhD student at the
还要上学。那时我已经重返校园了。我意识到，我又开始进行身体上的强迫行为。我意识到我复发了。于是我开始谷歌搜索。凭借我25岁的大脑，我终于找到了国际强迫症基金会。我意识到“暴露与反应预防”（ERP）是真实存在的，这才是强迫症的真正疗法。我简直不敢相信，25年来我从未听说过这个，而且我一直以来接受的治疗都是错误的。我终于开始接触ERP。我找回了大部分生活。我从一个GPA只有1.83的学生，重返校园，重修了所有课程并拿到了全A。我获得了心理学学士学位，并以4.0的成绩获得了神经科学硕士学位。我现在是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的博士生，
University of Wisconsin-Madison. I'm studying this very thing. My life looks completely different than it did riddled with OCD. And why I'm so passionate about talking about this is because so many people, like my story is not unique, going so long incorrectly treated, so long misdiagnosed. And this definitely needs to change. That's quite an incredible story. And that leads me to ask you, Dr. McKay, How does this get diagnosed? I mean, is there a test that you give to people? Do you do brain scans? How do you find out that somebody really has true OCD?
我正在研究这个课题。我的生活与被强迫症折磨时完全不同了。我之所以如此热衷于谈论这个话题，是因为有太多人——我的故事并不独特——长期接受错误的治疗，长期被误诊。这种情况绝对需要改变。这真是一个不可思议的故事。这让我不得不问你，麦凯博士，这是如何诊断的？我的意思是，你们会给人们做测试吗？你们会做脑部扫描吗？你们是如何确定某人真的患有强迫症的？
Sure. Well, look, before I start, OMA, I had not heard your story before. Really impressive. So I'm really happy to see that you've managed to overcome your OCD and come this far. Really, congratulations. And it's nice to see you giving back. So, as far, so coming to your question, Kim, it's a great question. And the story that Uma told is, unfortunately, off told about the misdiagnosis and mistreatment
当然。嗯，听着，在我开始之前，乌玛，我之前没听过你的故事。真的很令人印象深刻。所以我很高兴看到你已经成功克服了强迫症并走到了这一步。真的，恭喜你。很高兴看到你回馈社会。那么，回到你的问题，金，这是一个很好的问题。乌玛讲述的故事，不幸的是，关于误诊和错误治疗的故事经常被提及，
phase on the journey to finally finding correct treatment. So if we start with one thing that I hope will come from this podcast is that more people will understand what it takes to try and identify it. There are a number of very brief, readily administered tests that could be given that would at least give a hint as to whether or not more testing should be done to diagnose OCD. Most of it is frankly self-report in nature. We don't yet have a definitive brain scan to diagnose OCD, nor do we have really for any psychiatric condition a good, reliable brain scan.
这是最终找到正确治疗方法过程中的一个阶段。所以，如果我们从我希望通过这个播客实现的一件事开始，那就是让更多人了解识别它需要什么。有一些非常简短、易于实施的测试，可以提供一些线索，判断是否需要进行更多测试来诊断强迫症。坦率地说，大部分测试本质上是自我报告。我们目前还没有确定的脑部扫描来诊断强迫症，实际上，对于任何精神疾病，我们都没有可靠的脑部扫描。
But we do have tools at our disposal that in the hands of a skilled clinician can help point one in the right direction for how to measure this. So one of the measures is there's one that's freely available. It's really brief called the Obsessive Compulsive Inventory. If you'll pardon me with a brief little bit of self-promotion. My colleagues and I published a brief version of it. It's four items. It's four questions. We are really hoping that primary care physicians will start adopting it because it's literally something that could be part of an intake package that could be used. And we actually know a score that if you got above a certain score, it points one in the direction of whether or not someone might have OCD.
但我们确实拥有一些工具，在熟练的临床医生手中，可以帮助指明测量方向。其中一种是可以免费获取的，非常简短，叫做“强迫症量表”（Obsessive Compulsive Inventory）。请原谅我做一点简短的自我推销。我和我的同事发表了一个简短版本，只有四项，四个问题。我们真心希望初级保健医生能开始采用它，因为它完全可以作为入院检查的一部分。我们实际上知道一个分数，如果超过某个分数，就指向某人可能患有强迫症的方向。
So that part of it is an important first step. After that, it requires a trained mental health practitioner to then ask some important follow-up questions because a self-report questionnaire alone is really not enough, but we need to really know more about the setting, conditions under which this occurs, the degree to which it interferes with one's life. I mean, OMA's story is really quite intense in its conveys. about how much it can debilitate one. But also, her story is not uncommon in that many people who suffer it for so long are unaware that, wow, this is like, I don't have to live this way.
所以这部分是一个重要的第一步。在此之后，需要一位训练有素的心理健康从业者提出一些重要的后续问题，因为仅靠自我报告问卷是不够的。我们需要真正了解发生这种情况的环境、条件，以及它干扰个人生活的程度。我的意思是，乌玛的故事在传达它如何让人丧失功能方面确实非常强烈。但她的故事也不罕见，因为许多长期受苦的人并不知道，哇，原来我不需要这样生活。
I don't have to be consumed with the cost of things or whether I'm safe under these conditions. I mean, many people are kind of unaware of it because they get debilitated, but it also becomes something that they accommodate to. So those are some things that are worth paying attention to. I think practitioners can do a better job of it. Most suffer. go to primary care physicians and other medical and health professionals before they ever show up at a psychologist or psychiatrist office. And so I think there are some ways that this could be better understood in settings that people first go to it.
我不必被事物的代价或我在这些条件下是否安全所困扰。我的意思是，许多人对此并不知情，因为他们丧失了功能，但这也成了他们适应的一种状态。所以这些是值得注意的事情。我认为从业者可以做得更好。大多数患者在去看心理学家或精神科医生之前，都会先去看初级保健医生和其他医疗保健专业人员。所以我认为在人们首先去的地方，有一些方法可以更好地理解这一点。
And we'll save people just a ton of time and save them a lot of frustration and pain. Let's talk for a minute about treatment. Now, Uma, you've mentioned a few things that you were, that treatments were administered to you that didn't work. And I want to ask Dr. McKay, what does work? What are the proven treatments? And then what are the treatments that exacerbate the problem? Sure.
这将为人们节省大量时间，并减少许多挫折和痛苦。让我们花点时间谈谈治疗。现在，乌玛，你提到了一些你接受过但无效的治疗。我想问麦凯博士，什么才有效？什么是经过验证的治疗方法？哪些治疗方法反而会加重问题？当然。
Yeah, yeah. So the one established evidence-based treatment or, you know, what we call evidence-based treatment is that it's been studied carefully under a variety of conditions by independent groups, right? So it's not just one clinician or one researcher who said, I have this idea and then they keep doing it. It has to be independently shown. And the one that has actually been demonstrated for decades now is called exposure with response prevention, which Uma referred to before. Now, the term, I kind of feel funny about the term because it's got, it's unfortunate in a way.
是的，是的。所以，唯一确立的循证治疗，或者我们所说的循证治疗，是指在各种条件下经过独立小组仔细研究过的治疗方法，对吧？所以这不仅仅是一位临床医生或研究人员说“我有这个想法”然后一直做下去。它必须经过独立验证。几十年来，唯一被证明有效的方法叫做“暴露与反应预防”，也就是乌玛之前提到的。现在，这个术语，我对这个术语感觉有点奇怪，因为它在某种程度上是不幸的。
It's got like a public relations problem because it requires that someone help the client who's suffering from OCD practice doing the things that they're afraid of. And now, in the hands of someone who may be unskilled, this can be really a problem. And so, Uma made reference to harmful treatments. One way, that treatment can be harmful, like almost any other treatment, by the way. There are opportunities for people to do it poorly, in which case it comes out badly. So if we think about the day-to-day experience, the way Uma described her daily life, imagine, if you will, you're standing on the edge of a building with no guardrail.
它有一个公共关系问题，因为它要求有人帮助患有强迫症的客户练习做他们害怕的事情。现在，在不熟练的人手中，这可能会成为一个大问题。所以，乌玛提到了有害的治疗。这种治疗可能有害的一种方式，顺便说一下，几乎像任何其他治疗一样。人们有机会做得不好，结果就会很糟糕。所以如果我们考虑日常体验，乌玛描述她日常生活的方式，想象一下，你站在一栋没有护栏的建筑物边缘，
and the fear you might feel. That's probably, if I may, Uma, and I correct me if I'm wrong, I imagine, and what I've heard from other clients, that's the intense level of fear that they feel each day as they try to make these basic decisions. And so in order to treat this, we try to help people go through in a very gradual, paced, manageable way to encounter these things that they ordinarily might fear and then practice between sessions. And as they do this more and more, it becomes less scary. They find, oh, look, I can actually do these things and survive. And as they do that more and more, you can do
以及你可能感受到的恐惧。如果我没说错的话，乌玛，请纠正我，我想，正如我从其他客户那里听到的那样，这就是他们每天在试图做出这些基本决定时感受到的强烈恐惧。因此，为了治疗这一点，我们尝试帮助人们以一种非常渐进、有节奏、可控的方式去面对他们通常可能害怕的事情，然后在疗程之间进行练习。随着他们越来越多地这样做，它变得不那么可怕了。他们发现，哦，看，我实际上可以做这些事情并活下来。随着他们越来越多地这样做，你可以做
more and more advanced things and people find freedom in their life by doing it. So that's the main treatment. And by the way, it was the first effective treatment for OCD prior to that. In 1965, there was an article written that said, if someone comes to your office and they have OCD, do not treat them. Everything you do will harm them. That was literally the words in the American Psychiatric Association. The very next year is when exposure with response prevention began to get developed. So it's about almost 60 years that we've had variations on exposure with response prevention. The extension to that is that some specific forms of cognitive therapy are useful. So Uma made reference to traditional cognitive behavioral therapy. Traditional
越来越高级的事情，人们通过这样做在生活中找到了自由。所以这是主要的治疗方法。顺便说一下，这是强迫症的第一个有效治疗方法。在1965年，有一篇文章写道，如果有人来到你的办公室，他们患有强迫症，不要治疗他们。你所做的一切都会伤害他们。这字面上是美国精神病学协会的话。就在第二年，暴露与反应预防开始发展。所以我们有暴露与反应预防的变体已经有近60年了。它的延伸是，某些特定形式的认知疗法是有用的。所以乌玛提到了传统的认知行为疗法。传统的
cognitive behavioral therapy is where you help someone identify a way of thinking about things and you say, hey, let's challenge those assumptions. When you do that with OCD, it actually backfires badly because people will say to you things like, well, let's say if I use OMA as an example, if I may, Uma, since you expressed it so perfectly, the symptom expression, it's just, it's compelling for me to not go there. So if OMA's in the store and she's saying, I'm worried about buying baked beans because I don't know if I could spend $3 on this can of baked beans. Someone might ask you to then go down the rabbit hole of, well, what is the evidence that if you spend $3, that is going to be a problem?
认知行为疗法是帮助某人识别一种思考事物的方式，然后你说，嘿，让我们挑战这些假设。当你对强迫症这样做时，它实际上会产生严重的负面影响，因为人们会告诉你一些事情，比如，假设我以乌玛为例，如果可以的话，乌玛，既然你表达得如此完美，症状表达，对我来说不去想它很有吸引力。所以如果乌玛在商店里，她说，我担心买烤豆，因为我不知道我是否能花3美元买这罐烤豆。有人可能会要求你深入探讨，好吧，你花3美元会有问题的证据是什么？
And you get into this cycle that really basically is referred to as reassurance, which is basically a process that people with OCD probably do already. And that just makes things worse because now rather than demonstrating that, oh, I can spend $3 and not be destitute, they're instead getting reassurance that lasts very briefly. So that form of treatment is actually bad. A different form of cognitive therapy addresses main themes that we understand are associated with OCD, like, I have this inflated sense that there's danger facing me if I spend $3.
然后你陷入了这个循环，基本上被称为“寻求保证”，这基本上是强迫症患者可能已经在做的一个过程。这只会让事情变得更糟，因为现在他们不是在证明“哦，我可以花3美元而不会变得一贫如洗”，而是得到了只会持续很短时间的保证。所以那种治疗形式实际上是有害的。另一种形式的认知疗法解决了我们认为与强迫症相关的核心主题，比如，我有一种夸大的感觉，如果我花3美元，我就会面临危险。
What is the danger of spending $3? You start asking a different set of questions. And there's a collection of these that we can think of. There's concerns with perfectionism, concerns with responsibility. So people who have thoughts about harming others, they're worried that their thoughts have the power to lead them to action and therefore they're more responsible for what might happen later on to people, even if they just thought about harming them, but they never did anything. There's what they call over-importance of thoughts. So if I think it, it has greater
花3美元的危险是什么？你开始问一系列不同的问题。我们可以想到其中一些集合。有对完美主义的担忧，对责任的担忧。所以那些有伤害他人想法的人，他们担心他们的想法有能力导致他们采取行动，因此他们对后来可能发生的事情负有更多责任，即使他们只是想过伤害他们，但从未做过任何事。有所谓的“思想过度重要性”。所以如果我想到它，它就有更大的
potency, just in general. There's what they call overestimation of threat. There's intolerance of uncertainty. These are some of the main ways of thinking that people with OCD struggle with, and that cognitive therapy specifically for the condition is used to address. Well, Uma, I want to turn to you now and ask you if you've gotten some of this treatment. You seem to have your life on a good track right now. Do you have to constantly go through these exercises to keep yourself from slipping back into having the OCD symptoms? That's a really good question because I think in the answer touches on a lot of aspects of recovery. So for me, I started exposure and response prevention in 2020.
效力，总的来说。有所谓的“威胁高估”。有“对不确定性的不容忍”。这些是强迫症患者挣扎的一些主要思维方式，而专门针对该疾病的认知疗法就是用来解决这些问题的。好吧，乌玛，我想现在转向你，问问你是否接受过这种治疗。你现在似乎生活在正轨上。你是否必须不断进行这些练习，以防止自己滑回强迫症症状？这是一个非常好的问题，因为我认为答案触及了康复的许多方面。对我来说，我在2020年开始了暴露与反应预防。
2021, and it is now 2023 of this episode. So I, as Dr. McKay mentioned, I have comorbid OCD and PTSD, so that has complicated treatment a little bit. But overall, my trajectory of treatment is pretty common, which is that there is a lot of gains as soon as one starts doing ERP and they get under, they understand how it works and there's enough psychoeducation to buy into, if you will, ERP. But then from there, I mean, we, OCD is a chronic condition and that can sound scary. and it is, but with the proper tools, as you just talked about, I, first of all, I'm still an ERP. I'm doing it right after this episode. We're going to be downloading on this episode. Also, it is a, it's a practice for me because I have come down from scoring extreme on the
2021年，现在是本集录制的2023年。所以，正如麦凯博士提到的，我患有共病强迫症和创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），所以这让治疗变得有点复杂。但总的来说，我的治疗轨迹是很常见的，也就是说，一旦开始做ERP，他们就会获得很多收益，他们理解它是如何工作的，并且有足够的心理教育来接受ERP。但从那里开始，我的意思是，我们，强迫症是一种慢性疾病，这听起来可能很可怕，而且确实如此，但有了你刚才谈到的适当工具，首先，我仍然在做ERP。我在这集之后马上就要做。我们录完这集就要下载。此外，对我来说这是一种练习，因为我已经从得分极高降到了
Y Box, the Yale Brown obsessive compulsive scale that assesses the severity of OCD and diagnoses it sometimes. I've gone from extreme to severe. Sometimes I'm moderate to severe. So for me, my OCD is very strong. I have recovered enough. to gain my life. I wouldn't even say back because I didn't really have my life, honestly, before treatment. It was a very limited life. But with that being said, I still struggle deeply. And there are lots of themes and compulsions that I'm still working through myself right now.
耶鲁-布朗强迫症量表（Y-BOCS），它评估强迫症的严重程度并有时进行诊断。我已经从极重度降到了重度。有时我是中度到重度。所以对我来说，我的强迫症非常强烈。我已经康复到足以找回我的生活。我甚至不会说“找回”，因为老实说，在治疗之前我并没有真正拥有我的生活。那是一种非常受限的生活。但话虽如此，我仍然深陷挣扎。还有很多主题和强迫行为我目前还在自己努力克服。
So I struggle like we, I talked about before with mental compulsions. And they feel more difficult to deal with because it kind of feels like thinking, but it's just a lot of compulsive thinking. And themes that are more deeply rooted. So I think for me, ERP has been extremely helpful very quickly with almost more surface-level obsessions. And I don't say surface in a way to diminish the heaviness of how much impacted my life. But it really just feels more like this is OCD.
所以我像我们之前谈到的那样，与心理强迫行为作斗争。它们感觉更难处理，因为它们感觉有点像思考，但它们只是大量的强迫性思维。以及更根深蒂固的主题。所以我认为对我来说，ERP在处理更表层的强迫观念方面非常迅速且极其有帮助。我并不是说“表层”是为了贬低它对我生活影响的沉重感。但它真的感觉更像是“这是强迫症”。
I understand this is OCD. So I will do ERP and it works much more easily. It's also with physical compulsions. But for things much more related to honestly taboo themes with harm, with the fear of hurting other people, with my thoughts coming true. Because what I want to say is adding onto intrusive thoughts and harm, people with OCD, I guess everybody has intrusive thoughts. Everyone has a random thought of like just abhorrent things of things happening to people. Like what if I stab my dog?
我明白这是强迫症。所以我将进行ERP，它工作起来容易得多。身体强迫行为也是如此。但对于那些老实说与禁忌主题、伤害、害怕伤害他人、我的想法成真更相关的事情。因为我想说的是，除了侵入性想法和伤害之外，强迫症患者，我想每个人都有侵入性想法。每个人都会有随机的想法，比如对人们发生的可怕事情。比如“如果我刺伤我的狗怎么办？”
Like what if, you know, I'm driving under the bridge and it falls on me. And, you know, most people without OCD are able to be like, that's a weird thought. Okay. Like moving on, my brain just like did something. People with OCD have such a hyper responsible response to that thought. It's like, well, what if that thought's true? like, what if I actually want that? What if?
比如“如果，你知道，我开车经过桥下，它掉在我身上怎么办？”而且，你知道，大多数没有强迫症的人能够说，那是一个奇怪的想法。好吧，继续前进，我的大脑只是做了点什么。强迫症患者对那个想法有如此强烈的过度负责任的反应。就像，“好吧，如果那个想法是真的怎么办？”就像，“如果我真的想要那样怎么办？如果呢？”
And they don't. They don't want it at all. They hate that thought. They do not resonate that thought. It's ego dysonic. All that to say, those are what harm thoughts are and it can extend to literally anything ever and they're very scary. Those are some of the harder themes for me that I'm still working through in recovery.
事实并非如此。他们根本不想要这些念头。他们厌恶这种想法。他们对这种想法没有任何共鸣。这与他们的自我意识相悖。总而言之，这就是所谓的伤害性思维，它可以延伸到任何事物，而且非常可怕。这些是我在康复过程中仍在努力克服的一些较难的主题。
So yes, it can work in the short term of like you do your sessions and you learn ERP and you move on with your life. Also in the advocacy and community space for OCD. We talk about ERP being a lifestyle like because OCD can kind of latch on to anything that's scary in our life, especially. when we, the more we care about it, the more it can latch on. And so we have to keep doing ERP and keep understanding that we can tolerate the obsession and not do compulsions, which sounds very simple, but is extremely difficult. You know, if I could interject for a second, and maybe
所以，是的，短期内它是有效的，比如你完成疗程，学习了ERP（暴露与反应预防），然后继续你的生活。此外，在强迫症的倡导和社区领域，我们谈到ERP是一种生活方式，因为强迫症可以附着在我们生活中任何可怕的事情上，尤其是当我们越在意它时，它就越容易附着。因此，我们必须坚持进行ERP，并不断理解我们可以忍受强迫观念而不去执行强迫行为，这听起来很简单，但实际上极其困难。你知道，如果我能插一句，也许
this is a helpful way for listeners to understand a philosophy that guides treatment for OCD and to OMA's point about this being a chronic condition, what that means then is one has to take care of themselves in a very specific way. And the comparison that I use for clients that's sometimes reassuring, I use a dentistry comparison. So when you go to the dentist, you go regularly because you know that that's good for your teeth. You also, every now and then when you go to the dentist, the dentist says, oh, you need a filling or you need a root canal. And that means you're going to have to go a little bit more frequently. But you still have every single day a certain minimum level of care and maintenance that you have to do for your teeth. You have to brush your
这对听众来说是一种有益的方式，可以理解指导强迫症治疗的理念。关于Uma提到的这是一种慢性疾病，这意味着一个人必须以非常具体的方式照顾自己。我给客户使用的一个有时能起到安慰作用的类比是牙科类比。当你去看牙医时，你会定期去，因为你知道这对你的牙齿有好处。此外，当你偶尔去看牙医时，牙医会说，哦，你需要补牙或做根管治疗。这意味着你可能需要更频繁地去。但你每天仍然需要对牙齿进行最低限度的护理和维护。你必须刷
teeth. And sometimes like brushing your teeth is not that great. Like sometimes people get sensitive gums or you get like a piece of popcorn stuck between your teeth and you have to deal with that. Right. It's like a nuisance. When people get well enough with OCD that it's really better managed, they still need to do this regularly. And there will still be days where they go, oh, wow, you know, today was a tougher day. I had this in truth. of thought of harming someone. It was a lot stronger. It kind of reminded me of what it was like six months ago. And that's kind of like a brief filling that needs to be dealt with. Right. And every now and that actually, it might be even worse. You're like, wow, you know, I'm really
牙。有时刷牙感觉并不那么好。比如有时人们牙龈会敏感，或者牙齿间卡了爆米花渣，你必须处理它。对吧？这就像是一种麻烦。当人们的强迫症好转到得到良好控制时，他们仍然需要定期进行这种维护。而且仍然会有一些日子，他们会觉得，哦，哇，你知道，今天是很艰难的一天。我有了这种伤害他人的念头。它强烈得多。这让我想起了六个月前的情况。这就像是一个需要处理的小补牙。对吧？有时情况甚至可能更糟。你会觉得，哇，你知道，我真的
stuck on this harm thought and I'm really concerned again about a whole litany of things with germs and contamination. Well, that's like now the root canal. So we really have to view it more through this lens of regular maintenance and how to achieve wellness by integrating this component of treatment into your life, beginning with a period of time where it might eat up a lot of time and then moving to a period of time in your life where it might be a regular daily occurrence. And I also want to add on to that analogy really quickly because I know I said it was chronic and that could at face value be taken as, oh, well, that's just so unfortunate. Like, why even do treatment when I have to live with it my whole life?
被这个伤害念头困住了，我又开始担心一连串关于细菌和污染的事情。好吧，那现在就像是根管治疗了。所以我们真的必须通过这种定期维护的视角来看待它，并通过将这一治疗组成部分融入你的生活来实现健康，从一开始可能占用大量时间，到后来可能成为日常生活中定期发生的事情。我还想快速补充一下这个类比，因为我知道我说过它是慢性的，从表面上看，这可能会被理解为，哦，好吧，那真是太不幸了。既然我必须终身与它共存，为什么还要接受治疗呢？
well, kind of with the analogy of having maybe a cavity that you didn't get treated for like 10 years. I had one for two years. So I know what that feels like. And just the amount of pain in it taking over your mouth all day every day, like once you get your cavity filled and then you brush your teeth and you might get a cavity again. But for the most part, like until you get that next cavity, you're still living in far less pain and in far more freedom. So it's still worth getting the cavity filled and still worth, and there's still so much freedom. So yes, there's a lot of hope with OCD, even when it is chronic. Exactly. Right. Right. I love that. That's great. Thanks for building on that. So another question occurs to me going back to something that Uma said earlier, which is that
嗯，就像有一个你十年没治疗的蛀牙的类比。我有一个蛀牙了两年。所以我知道那是什么感觉。一旦你补了牙，然后你刷牙，你可能又会蛀牙。但大多数情况下，在下一次蛀牙之前，你仍然生活在痛苦少得多、自由得多的状态中。所以补牙仍然是值得的，而且仍然有很大的自由。所以是的，强迫症即使是慢性的，也有很多希望。完全正确。对。我喜欢这个。太棒了。感谢你的补充。那么，回到Uma之前提到的一个问题，我想到另一个问题，那就是
she thinks that she was born with OCD. And I want to ask you, Dr. McKay, are people born with it? Is it acquired? When does it first manifest? How would you know if you're seeing it in a child, for example? Yeah. So we use. usually think of OCD as having two distinct ages of onset. There's a young child version. And so children who develop it where it's really evident to everyone around them, usually around ages six or seven. What makes it a little more complicated is that there's a developmental stage where children exhibit compulsive behavior, where it's expected and normal. And so when we think about the birth of a child who may have a future with OCD, they probably temperamentally
她认为她天生就有强迫症。我想问你，麦凯博士，人们是天生就有强迫症吗？它是后天获得的吗？它最早在什么时候表现出来？例如，你怎么知道你是否在孩子身上看到了它？是的。所以我们通常认为强迫症有两个不同的发病年龄。一个是幼儿期。所以，那些在周围人看来非常明显的儿童，通常在六七岁左右发病。让情况变得有点复杂的是，有一个发育阶段，孩子们会表现出强迫行为，这是预期之中且正常的。所以当我们想到一个未来可能患有强迫症的孩子的出生时，他们可能在气质上
do exhibit it early on. We don't know definitively how someone arrives with OCD, but we do know that there are certain dispositions that increase the odds, and those kids usually develop it early. There's then a little more later onset, which is in the teen years. And by the way, for listeners to this podcast, if you've had other people talk about other psychiatric conditions, most conditions have an age of onset in the teen years. The teen years are a period of intense social stress that is a way in which a lot of different anxiety disorders, depression, and other psychiatric conditions show up. So it's not surprising that OCD would have this other second major age of onset. So kids who develop it early, they probably temperamentally are more
确实很早就表现出来了。我们不知道一个人是如何患上强迫症的，但我们确实知道某些性格倾向会增加患病几率，而这些孩子通常很早就发病。然后是稍晚一点的发病期，即青少年时期。顺便说一句，对于这个播客的听众，如果你听过其他人谈论其他精神疾病，大多数疾病的发病年龄都在青少年时期。青少年时期是一个充满巨大社会压力的时期，这是许多不同的焦虑症、抑郁症和其他精神疾病表现出来的方式。所以强迫症有这第二个主要发病年龄并不奇怪。所以那些很早就发病的儿童，他们可能在气质上更
anxious, more prone to developing this because of circumstances in their environment that naturally would have led them there. So what I like to tell people is that you probably would have developed it no matter what, right? To spend time in more traditional psychotherapies where you might try to break down behaviors of one's parents, to look for conditions that gave rise to it, It's usually kind of a fruitless endeavor. And frankly, it doesn't promote any kind of wellness anyway. But we do know that there are temperaments, as they call it, ways that you respond emotionally to the world that you have when you arrive
焦虑，由于环境中的情况自然导致他们走向这一步，因此更容易患上这种疾病。所以我喜欢告诉人们的是，无论如何你可能都会患上它，对吧？花时间在更传统的心理治疗中，试图剖析父母的行为，寻找导致它的条件，这通常是一种徒劳的努力。坦率地说，它也不会促进任何形式的健康。但我们确实知道，正如他们所说的，气质，即你来到这个世界时对世界做出情感反应的方式，
that may set the stage for this. Now, Uma, you've talked about having some comorbidity, some other issues in addition to having OCD. How has that affected your overall well-being? and is that really common as you're dealing as an advocate, do you see that a lot in people? Yeah. So there's actually, in terms of the research done for OCD and especially for therapeutics, namely right now, there's a lot of research being done with ketamine and psychedelics for
可能会为这种情况奠定基础。现在，Uma，你谈到除了强迫症之外还有一些共病，一些其他问题。这如何影响了你的整体健康？在你作为倡导者处理这些问题时，你是否在人们身上经常看到这种情况？是的。所以实际上，就强迫症的研究，特别是治疗学而言，目前，关于氯胺酮和迷幻药用于
OCD, for example. A huge problem that researchers are facing is that they have a quote unquote dirty population, meaning that people don't just have OCD. They also have many other comorbid disorders. And so we're not truly sure if we're working specifically with OCD. And I think all that to say that it's very common to have comorbidities, especially, I think, some of the highest ones are major depressive disorder, generalized anxiety disorder. One of them that I'm very particularly interested in is post-traumatic stress disorder.
强迫症的研究非常多。研究人员面临的一个巨大问题是，他们拥有一个所谓的“脏”人群，这意味着人们不仅仅患有强迫症。他们还患有许多其他共病。所以我们并不确定我们是否专门在研究强迫症。我认为总而言之，患有共病是非常普遍的，尤其是，我认为其中最高发的是重度抑郁症、广泛性焦虑症。我特别感兴趣的一个是创伤后应激障碍。
And I think what's super important to note, though, because I face this question a lot in my research and an advocacy is, well, is OCD just a form of these disorders then? Or is it just a coping mechanism for these other disorders? And OCD, while it does have a lot of overlap, is also a distinct disorder with distinct functionality that requires distinct treatment. But to your question of my overall wellness, I think just on surface level having these comorbidities and the fact that it was far easier to find my other disorders before OCD just delayed the treatment that I could have received for so long, which really wrecked me for so much of my life.
我认为非常重要的一点是，因为我在研究和倡导中经常遇到这个问题，那就是，强迫症只是这些疾病的一种形式吗？还是它只是这些其他疾病的一种应对机制？强迫症虽然确实有很多重叠之处，但它也是一种独特的疾病，具有独特的功能，需要独特的治疗。但回到你关于我整体健康的问题，我认为从表面上看，患有这些共病，以及在强迫症之前更容易发现我的其他疾病这一事实，只是推迟了我本可以接受的治疗，这在我的生活中摧毁了我很长一段时间。
And I'm working through the grief of how much life I lost due to undiagnosed and untreated OCD. I mean, like, the amount I have gained in my life in the last two to three years from proper treatment. Like, it's just mind-blowing what life, how much is possible for my life with proper treatment. So I think on surface level, just those comorbidities kind of mass the OCD, but also in general, like, dealing with so many conditions at once and the severity of it all, it's really taxing. And I think it's hard to kind of parse them entirely apart as to what's the most debilitating, but I will say because of the added burden of OCD being so underdiagnosed and also because OCD has this way of causing and casting doubt on top of everything in my life
我正在努力克服因未诊断和未治疗的强迫症而失去生活的悲伤。我的意思是，在过去两三年里，通过适当的治疗，我在生活中获得的收益。这简直令人难以置信，通过适当的治疗，我的生活会有多少可能。所以我认为从表面上看，这些共病掩盖了强迫症，但总的来说，同时处理这么多疾病及其严重程度，确实非常累人。我认为很难完全区分哪种是最令人衰弱的，但我会说，由于强迫症被如此低估，而且强迫症有一种在我的生活中对一切事物造成和投下怀疑的方式，
and just causing this level of unsafety that the other disorders don't really do as much. It definitely doesn't make things very fun. If I could add for a second, because I described exposure therapy, exposure with response prevention, and Ouma mentioned it also, and she, I think, is a great. great living example of someone who has benefited from it and gotten freedom from her OCD symptoms, that if you look online, so listeners to this podcast may now go further and look up exposure with response prevention and the descriptions that are out there very widely. Some of them fail to do it justice. So I want to say out loud and with the strongest voice I possibly can
并造成这种其他疾病并不太会造成的这种不安全感。这绝对不会让事情变得很有趣。如果我能补充一下，因为我描述了暴露疗法，即暴露与反应预防，Uma也提到了它，我认为她是受益于此并从强迫症症状中获得自由的一个很好的活生生的例子，如果你在网上查看，这个播客的听众现在可能会进一步查找暴露与反应预防以及广泛存在的描述。其中一些未能公正地对待它。所以我想要大声地说出来，并以我所能发出的最强烈的声音说，
that conducting exposure with response prevention for someone who suffers from OCD is probably the most compassionate thing you can do if it's done properly. There are all kinds of descriptions out there that characterize it based upon the exposure part, and they also sometimes capture elements that are gleaned from execution by therapists who maybe understand what they're supposed to do, but do it in elegantly. And so that's an error of blaming the treatment when actually it was due to an inartful or unskilled therapy execution. So I can. I can't stress it enough. It is really the most compassionate thing you could do. It provides the fastest relief of any treatment we know when done properly. And so I really feel like it's so
对于强迫症患者来说，如果操作得当，进行暴露与反应预防可能是你能做的最富有同情心的事情。外面有各种各样的描述，根据暴露部分来描述它，它们有时也会捕捉到一些从治疗师执行中收集到的元素，这些治疗师可能理解他们应该做什么，但执行得不够优雅。所以这是将治疗归咎于错误的错误，而实际上这是由于治疗执行不当或不熟练造成的。所以我怎么强调都不为过。这确实是你能做的最富有同情心的事情。如果操作得当，它能提供我们所知的任何治疗中最快的缓解。所以我真的觉得
important to really highlight that for anybody listening. What about drug therapy, though? I'm wondering since Zuma brought that up, are there drug therapies that are effective for OCD? So there have been a lot of drugs tested for OCD and are on the market for OCD. That also has about a 45 or 50-year history in the medical research literature. The one drug that got this started is called chlamypramine. The trade name is anaphrinil. The challenge with that drug, as I understand it, I'm not a medical doctor, but I know enough about medication that I could talk about it with mild competency, is that there are side effects that people find to be unpleasant. The newer antidepressants, and the class of drugs, by the way, that are most likely to be used for OCD or antidepressants.
强调这一点对任何听众来说都非常重要。那么药物治疗呢？我很好奇，既然Uma提到了这一点，是否有对强迫症有效的药物治疗？所以有很多药物被测试用于强迫症，并且在市场上用于强迫症。这在医学研究文献中也有大约45到50年的历史。第一个开始这种治疗的药物叫做氯丙咪嗪。商品名是安那芬尼。据我所知，这种药物的挑战在于，我不是医学博士，但我对药物了解得足够多，可以以轻微的胜任力谈论它，那就是人们发现有令人不快的副作用。较新的抗抑郁药，顺便说一句，最有可能用于强迫症的药物类别是抗抑郁药。
So, Clomipramine was the first that really showed benefit. The side effects people find to be difficult to tolerate, though. And so the newer ones, and when I say newer, it's like as of Prozac and on, so it's still like a 35-year history, are better tolerated medications. So most prescribers who treat OCD regularly start with newer serotonin reuptake inhibitors. So the neurotransmitter that's been implicated in OCD is serotonin. Prozac is one drug that's often prescribed, Louvox, aka both of these you can get generic. So fluoxatine for Plovak, fluvoxamine for Louvox. Certraline, aka Zoloft, is also widely prescribed.
所以，氯丙咪嗪是第一个真正显示出益处的药物。但人们发现副作用难以忍受。所以较新的药物，当我说是较新时，是指百忧解以后的药物，所以它仍然有35年的历史，是耐受性更好的药物。因此，大多数定期治疗强迫症的处方医生从较新的血清素再摄取抑制剂开始。所以与强迫症有关的神经递质是血清素。百忧解是一种经常开出的药物，Luvox，也就是这两种你都可以买到仿制药。所以氟西汀用于百忧解，氟伏沙明用于Luvox。舍曲林，也就是左洛复，也被广泛开出。
Newer medications than that are things like Lexapro, which is commonly prescribed. And as you get to newer and newer medications, what they call selectivity, the degree that they target only serotonin and don't end up targeting other neurotransmitters, which is where the side effects come into play, is what is the benefit for the newer one. So let's say Lexapro really only target serotonin. There aren't too many other neurotransmitters at a target so people don't have as many side effects. The downside is that the research suggests that they may not necessarily provide as much benefit. And the bottom line with all of this is that most of the research has suggested that medication alone is generally not sufficient.
比那更新的药物是像来士普这样的药物，它很常用。随着你接触到越来越新的药物，所谓的选择性，即它们仅靶向血清素而不靶向其他神经递质的程度，这就是副作用发挥作用的地方，是较新药物的益处。所以假设来士普真的只靶向血清素。它没有太多其他靶向的神经递质，所以人们没有那么多副作用。缺点是研究表明它们不一定能提供那么多的益处。所有这一切的底线是，大多数研究表明，仅靠药物治疗通常是不够的。
So most sufferers at some point probably will need to meet with a mental health professional who does not prescribe in order to help alleviate their symptoms. But medication can take the edge off and some people find real meaningful and lasting benefit from it. So we should really pay attention to that. It's an important facet of how treatment can be done properly and comprehensively. The neuroscientist in me wants to just add a few more things to that. Absolutely. A newer line of research too is on glutamate modulators. So glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter that's also implicated in OCD as well.
所以大多数患者在某个时候可能需要会见一位不负责开药的心理健康专业人员，以帮助减轻他们的症状。但药物可以缓解症状，有些人从中获得了真正有意义和持久的益处。所以我们真的应该注意这一点。这是治疗如何能够被正确和全面地执行的一个重要方面。我体内的神经科学家想要再补充几点。绝对可以。一个新的研究方向也是关于谷氨酸调节剂。所以谷氨酸是一种兴奋性神经递质，也与强迫症有关。
So that's being looked at as well as psychedelic treatments for the purposes of modulating many. other types of neurons and neurotransmitters. Additionally, I think when people hear the word antidepressant, they think, like, oh, so it's just a form of depression. It's not. And antidepressants do help with depression, but also they help with many other things because they're acting on serotonergic neurons. Also, specifically for OCD, patients tend to need a far higher dose of an antidepressant or an SSRI than people, than just for depression. And the last thing I want to say is just exactly highlighting what Dr. McKay said about the research showing that, yes, of course, like medications can make an impact, but they typically need exposure and response prevention,
所以这也在被研究，以及用于调节许多其他类型的神经元和神经递质的迷幻药治疗。此外，我认为当人们听到“抗抑郁药”这个词时，他们会想，哦，所以它只是一种抑郁症的形式。事实并非如此。抗抑郁药确实有助于治疗抑郁症，但它们也有助于治疗许多其他事情，因为它们作用于血清素能神经元。此外，专门针对强迫症，患者往往需要比仅用于抑郁症的人高得多的抗抑郁药或SSRIs剂量。我想说的最后一件事是，正如麦凯博士所说，研究表明，是的，当然，药物可以产生影响，但它们通常需要暴露与反应预防，
or there's far higher and more positive outcomes with exposure and response prevention, especially in comparing if one just did ERP versus medication, if they had to pick one or the other, which is not the case, but if they had to, ERP is more efficacious than medication alone, and medication can be adjunctive and helpful as well, but ERP is the cornerstone of treatment. So just to tie up loose ends here, let me ask an overarching question to you both, since you're both doing work in these areas, what do you consider the big unanswered questions and what are you working on now where you're really hoping to maybe break through? Uma, you want to take that first?
或者暴露与反应预防会有更高和更积极的结果，特别是在比较如果一个人只做ERP与药物治疗，如果他们必须二选一，虽然事实并非如此，但如果他们必须这样做，ERP比单独药物治疗更有效，药物可以作为辅助和有益的，但ERP是治疗的基石。所以为了结束这里的问题，让我问你们两个一个总体问题，因为你们都在这些领域工作，你们认为什么是重大的未解之谜，你们现在正在研究什么，你们真的希望在那里取得突破？Uma，你想先来吗？
I, as a neuropsycho-pharmacologist, want to understand why on earth OCD brains exist. What is the neural circuitry? What exactly is going on? hopefully we can develop novel therapeutics and novel interventions. I also think that with the research has already been done, it's already pretty evident that there is a narrow developmental component and that above all, it is a brain disorder. It is not a choice. It is not a quirk.
作为一名神经精神药理学家，我想了解强迫症大脑为什么存在。神经回路是什么？到底发生了什么？希望我们能开发出新的疗法和新的干预措施。我还认为，随着已经完成的研究，已经很明显存在一个狭窄的发育组成部分，最重要的是，它是一种大脑疾病。这不是一种选择。这不是一种怪癖。
It is not an adjective in that there are unique brain circuit features that are giving rise to these horrific experiences in people. I also want to understand if there are differences in physical versus mental compulsions in the way that it is enforced in the brain because it seems to be like there's sometimes a divergence in the way people recover in that way, at least in my experience and others as well. And I think Dr. McKay is also doing amazing work to further the field and just accessibility and understanding of this disorder. So I'll let him take it away as well. Well, that's exciting what you're working on Uma. And I'm so glad that you're joining the field in this area. So that's great. Well,
它不是一个形容词，因为有独特的大脑回路特征导致了人们这些可怕的经历。我还想了解身体强迫行为与心理强迫行为在大脑中的执行方式是否存在差异，因为在我看来，至少在我的经验和其他人中，人们在恢复方式上似乎有时存在分歧。我认为麦凯博士也在做令人惊叹的工作来推动该领域的发展，并提高对这种疾病的可及性和理解。所以我也会让他来谈谈。嗯，你正在研究的东西很令人兴奋，Uma。我很高兴你加入这个领域。所以这太棒了。嗯，
and to what you're asking about, Kim. So my focus of late has been, as As Asuma said, I really, I feel it's so important that more people, first of all, be able to identify it, right? The fact that people go undiagnosed and then when they get diagnosed don't get the proper treatment, to me is really a tragedy, particularly when the treatment has been available and known for as long as it has been. So, like, I entered the psychology workforce in 1993. And at that time, exposure with response prevention was known. It's not like when I entered the workforce, people were like, I don't know what to do about OCD. We knew what to do then.
关于你问的问题，Kim。所以我最近的重点是，正如Uma所说，我真的觉得非常重要的一点是，首先，更多的人能够识别它，对吧？人们未被诊断，然后在被诊断后没有得到适当的治疗，对我来说确实是一个悲剧，特别是当治疗已经像现在这样可用和已知了这么久的时候。所以，我是在1993年进入心理学工作岗位的。那时，暴露与反应预防是已知的。并不是说当我进入工作岗位时，人们就像，我不知道该怎么处理强迫症。我们那时就知道该怎么做。
And here it is now, all these years later, and there's still a poverty of availability of treatment. To me, that's like if you said we know penicillin works, but we can't get it to everybody. So that's, to me, is really just horrible. And we need to do better in that front. At the same time, there are these giant areas that we don't really fully understand. understand yet. So we really haven't talked about it. And it's probably a topic for a different podcast, frankly, is, well, what is the role of some other emotional states? The focus of our discussion was anxiety, right? Most people with OCD immediately report, I'm anxious. This is terrifying.
而现在，这么多年过去了，治疗的可及性仍然很匮乏。对我来说，这就像你说我们知道青霉素有效，但我们无法让每个人都得到它。所以这对我来说真的很可怕。我们需要在这方面做得更好。与此同时，还有一些我们还没有完全理解的巨大领域。我们还没有真正谈论过它。坦率地说，这可能是另一个播客的主题，那就是，其他一些情绪状态的作用是什么？我们讨论的重点是焦虑，对吧？大多数强迫症患者立即报告说，我很焦虑。这太可怕了。
But about 50% of all sufferers, whether it's their main symptom or it's a secondary symptom of OCD, struggle with contamination concerns. And that brings into the, the focus, things are right, like Uma. And what suddenly gets wrapped up in this are things about disgust. And so I only talk about it briefly. So I guess it'll be a teaser, people who are listening, email me or invite me to another podcast. Disgust is designed at its core to help prevent us from getting poisoned by stuff, whether
但大约50%的患者，无论是作为主要症状还是强迫症的次要症状，都在与污染担忧作斗争。这带来了焦点，事情是对的，比如Uma。突然被卷入其中的是关于厌恶的事情。所以我只是简短地谈论它。所以我猜这会是一个预告，正在听的人，给我发电子邮件或邀请我参加另一个播客。厌恶的核心设计是为了帮助防止我们被东西毒害，无论是
it be through our skin or through our mouth. And so this is an animating focus for a big portion of people. people of OCD, not to mention other psychological conditions. And we don't really know what to do with that yet. I mean, we have kind of a sense, but we're really not good at it yet. So that, I think, is one of a number of important frontiers that we need to deal with. And OMA will appreciate this. We know for disgust whole different neural circuitry is involved.
通过我们的皮肤还是通过我们的嘴。所以这是很大一部分强迫症患者的推动焦点，更不用说其他心理疾病了。我们还不知道该怎么处理它。我的意思是，我们有一种感觉，但我们还不是很擅长。所以我认为这是我们需要处理的众多重要前沿之一。Uma会理解这一点。我们知道厌恶涉及完全不同的神经回路。
The brain area is involved in fear are not the same ones for disgust. So that means we probably have to deal with it differently when it comes to psychological treatments or any other kinds of medical interventions. And I want to come full circle to where we started at the beginning about the misconceptions of OCD because, as Dr. McKay mentioned, treatment is available. Resources are available, but why are people going so long misdiagnosed and untreated? Largely, that's because OCD faces a unique barrier that other psychological disorders don't, which is this complete misunderstanding and misrepresentation of what it is. And so I think bridging that gap really starts with episodes like
涉及恐惧的大脑区域与厌恶的大脑区域不同。这意味着当涉及到心理治疗或任何其他类型的医疗干预时，我们可能必须以不同的方式处理它。我想回到我们开始时关于强迫症误解的话题，因为正如麦凯博士提到的，治疗是可用的。资源是可用的，但为什么人们被误诊和未治疗这么久？很大程度上，这是因为强迫症面临着其他心理疾病所没有的独特障碍，那就是对它是什么的完全误解和歪曲。所以我认为弥合这一差距确实始于像
this on large platforms where we get to raise awareness for what real OCD is and making sure that people are more aware early on that OCD is not a choice. It is not something people like and that repetitive thoughts, intrusive thoughts and repetitive physical and mental behaviors can be a disorder that they can be treated for. So that just full circle, this is why we need to raise awareness. This is why advocacy exists on such a large scale for OCD specifically and why people like me dedicate their lives to talking about it. It's not just because we want to talk about how hard our life is. It's because we're trying to make sure other people don't suffer as long as we did, unnecessarily. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. It's been a fascinating conversation.
这样的大型平台上的剧集，我们有机会提高对什么是真正强迫症的认识，并确保人们更早地意识到强迫症不是一种选择。这不是人们喜欢的东西，重复的想法、侵入性想法以及重复的身体和心理行为可能是一种可以治疗的疾病。所以回到原点，这就是为什么我们需要提高认识。这就是为什么强迫症有如此大规模的倡导，以及为什么像我这样的人致力于谈论它。这不仅仅是因为我们想谈论我们的生活有多艰难。这是因为我们正在努力确保其他人不会像我们一样遭受那么长时间的不必要的痛苦。嗯，我要感谢你们两位今天加入我。这是一次引人入胜的对话。
I'm sure we could go on longer. And Dr. McKay, maybe we'll get back to disgust at some point. That is a topic that I would like to talk about. So I appreciate- I think Huma should join us for that. Oh, okay. Absolutely. Yeah. We may all meet again then. Absolutely. We're a team. That's right. All right. Well, thank you both. It's been really great. It was a pleasure. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我相信我们可以继续谈下去。麦凯博士，也许我们会在某个时候回到厌恶的话题。那是我想要谈论的一个话题。所以我很感激——我认为Uma应该加入我们。哦，好的。绝对可以。是的。我们到时候可能都会再见面。绝对的。我们是一个团队。没错。好的。嗯，谢谢你们两位。这真的很棒。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。
And if you like what you've heard, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condyenne。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是 Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。